Dewa, ressun (lesson) 4 no kanji no shoukai
shimasu.
Ee ressun (lesson) 4 de wa korera no jyuukyuu
no kanji wo shoukai shimasu.
Mazu, saishou no kanji.
Ee, kono kanji desu keredomo, imi wa give
toka grant no imi ga arimasu.
Amari ii story jyanai kamoshirenai desukeredo
mo, imagine this part like some sort of a
key, and this is a hand, so someone gives
a key to your concerns, key to your questions
or answer to your question to iu no de, kore
give no imi ga arimasu.
De, yomikata nan desu keredomo, onyomi de
yo to iu no ga arimasu.
Tatoeba, kyuuyo, kore salary.
Ee, sorekara kanyosuru, kore to participate
in.
nani nani ni kanyosuru to iu no de, ma, eeto
to participate in, particle wa ni desu.
Sorekara, kiyosuru, kore to contribute.
Toku ni, eeto nani nani ni kiyosuru, okane
wo ma contribution no imi ga arimasu.
Kunyomi nan desu keredomo,
kore wa mo minna yoku shitteru to
omoimasu, ataeru, ee, to give.
Ee, nani nani wo nani nani ni ataeru to iu
tsukaikata desu.
Dewa, tsugi no kanji desu.
Ee, kono kanji desu keredomo, imi wa inside
to iu imi desu.
Ee, kore daijoubu desu ne, kore person.
So there is a person inside his house, ma
kore inside to iu no de, inside to iu imi
ga arimasu.
Yomikata nan desu keredomo, onyomi de nai
to iu yomikata desu.
Ee, tatoeba, naiyou, kore content.
Sorekara, naibu, kore interior.
Kono bu to iu no wa paato (part) dakara, naibu,
inside part to iu no de, interior.
Sorekara, naika, ee, kore internal medicine.
Sorekara kanai, kore wa my wife desu yo ne,
uchi no naka ni iru no hito, ma my wife.
Hoka no hito no wife no koto wa okusan to
iu iimasu kara kiotsukete kudasai.
Sorekara, kokunai, kuni no naka.
Sorekara, sono hanta toshita kokugai, kuni
no soto.
Sorekara, inai, kore wa within.
Ee, sorekara annai suru to iu no de, to guide
to iu imi ga arimasu.
Kunyomi nan desu keredomo, uchi to iu yomikata
ga arimasu.
Ee, uchigawa, kore side no imi desu.
So inside.
Hantai gawa wa sotogawa, outside.
Sorekara uchikina to iu no de, shy to iu na
adjective ga arimasu.
Ee, kore, eeto gaiki, kore wa tsukawanaide
kudasai.
Ee, shy, kore dake desu.
Kiotsukete kudasai.
Hai. Dewa tsugi no kanji desu.
Ee, kono kanji desu keredomo, imi wa right
toka correct no imi ga arimasu.
Iroiro na oboekata ga aru kato omoimasu keredomo,
one way to remember this kanji would be when
you hit the corner or the dead end, you need
to stop.
Kore wa stop, tomaru to iu kanji desu.
So when you hit the dead end, you need to
stop that’s the right thing to do to iu
no de, right, correct to iu imi ga arimasu.
De, yomikata nan desu keredomo, onyomi sei,
shou to iu no ga arimasu.
Seikai, kore wa correct answer.
Sorekara, seigi, kore, justice.
Seikaku na, na adjective nan desu keredomo,
accurate.
Ee, kore no hantai, kore fuseikaku na, kore
wa negation no ano prefix desu yo ne.
Sorekara fuseina, kore unjust.
Kore mo na adjective desu.
Sorekara, ee doushi, verb de shuusei suru,
kore to revise, repair to iu imi ga arimasu.
Kunyomi no hou nan desu keredomo, tada toka
masa.
Tadashii, kore wa correct.
Tadashii kotae desu, correct answer toka.
Sorekara, masa ni, surely to iu ee adverb
no tsukaikata mo arimasu.
Dewa, tsugi no kanji desu.
Ee, kono kanji desu keredomo, imi wa etiquette,
rite, courtesy, gratitude to iu imi ga arimasu.
De, component nan desu keredomo, kono component
imi toshite wa alter no imi ga arimasu.
So in front of alter, someone is praying on
her knees to iu no de, ma etiquette, that’s
the right way to pray, etiquette toka courtesy,
gratitude to iu imi ga arimasu.
Ee, onyomi nan desu keredomo, rei toka rai.
Kunyomi wa arimasen.
Shitsurei suru, kore to be impolite desu yo
ne.
Kore ushinau, to lose.
So, etiquette wo ushinau no de to be impolite,
shitsureisuru.
Ee, demo ano shitsureishimasu to iu no, tatoeba
sensei no office ni hairu toki,
ee sono toki ni wa shitsureishimasu.
Sorekara, ato mo shitsureishimashita, kore
wa doumo sumimasen to iu imi, imi ni narimasu.
Tsugi reigi nan desu keredomo, kore wa manner,
courtesy.
Sorekara, sharei, reward, kore wa taitei okane
desu.
Sharei toshite, tatoeba, ichiman en sashiagemasu.
Konna iikata e tsukaikata wo shimasu.
Sorekara orei, kore wa appreciation,
gratitude.
Tatoeba desu ne, tasukete moratte toki wa,
orei wo iwanakereba ikemasen.
Konno tsukaikata wo shimasu.
Ee tsugi no kanji desu.
Ee kono kanji desu keredomo, to turn toward
toka face toward, sorekara ma, over there
toka te iu sonna imi wo arimasu.
De, ma oboekata nan desu keredomo, ma, something
is happening beyond the limits of the house
to iu no de, it’s face toward, aruiwa over
there.
Sonna imi ga dedekimasu.
Yomikata nan desu keredomo, onyomi de kou.
Ma, koujoushin to iu no de, aspiration to
iu kotoba ga arimasu.
Sorekara, houkou, kore wa ii desu ne, ma direction.
Sorekara, keikou, kore, tendency.
Nani nani suru keikou suru arimasu to iu tsukaikata
wo shimasu.
Sorekara kunyomi nan desu keredomo, mukou,
over there.
Ato desu ne, ee tokidoki tsukawareru no ga,
kodomo mukei.
Kore wa for children.
Ee kodomo ni appropriate na to iu tsukaikata
desu.
Tatoeba, kodomo muke no eega, sorekara joshei
mukei no, ee, shouhin toka, otona muke toka,
konna tsukaikata mo shimasu.
Dewa, tsugi no kanji desu.
Ee, kono kanji nan desu keredomo, imi wa form
toka to achieve no imi ga arimasu.
Ee, chotto component mite ikimashou.
Ee, kono part, ee koko crossing wa jitsu wa
nain desu keredomo, ma, man, ichi man, ten
thousand.
Ee, sorekara, kono paato (part) nan desu keredomo,
kore wa spears no imi ga arimasu.
So, ten thousand soldiers with spears to form
a strong army to iu no de, ma to form sorekara
to achieve no imi ga arimasu.
Yomikata nan desu keredomo, onyomi de sei
toka jou to iu no ga arimasu.
Ee, seikou suru, to succeed.
Daijoubu desu ne.
Kono hantai wa shippai suru desu.
Sorekara, seichou suru, to grow.
Ee, sansei suru, kore wa to agree.
Nani nani ni sansei suru to iu tsukaikata
desu.
Sorekara, kansei suru, kore wa to complete.
Nani nani wo kansei suru.
Sorekara, seiseki, grade.
Ee, daigaku no seiseki wa yokatta desu.
Aruiwa kono class no seiseki wa yokatta desu.
Ee, sorekara, seijinshiki.
Kore wa coming-of-age celebration.
Nihon de seijinshiki wa ichigatsu jyuu gonichi
ni arimasu.
Kunyomi no hou nan desu keredomo, amari minna
wa tsukawanai kamoshirenai desu keredomo,
kore naru, to become.
Ano kanji wo tsukawanakute mo hiragana de
daijoubu desu.
Tatoeba, samuku naru toka, sono become desu.
Sorekara nasu tte iu no de, to accomplish
to iu doushi mo arimasu.
Tsugi no kanji desu.
Ee, kono kanji desu keredomo, imi wa to oppose,
opposite, against to iu imi ga arimasu.
De, ano, omoshiroi oboekata no hanashi ga
nain desu keredomo,
kochira hidari gawa kore wa ii desu ne,
ano bun tte iu no desu ga,
ano, literary toka sorekara letter sonna imi
ga arimasu.
Sorekara migi gawa kono paato (part) nan desu
keredomo, kore sun to yomun deskeredo mo,
it used to be used as a kind of you know measurement
unit like inch.
De a little bit toka few sou iu imi mo ariamsu.
De yomikata nan desu keredomo, ee onyomi de
tai toka tsui tte iu no ga arimasu.
Tatoeba, hantai suru, to oppose.
Kore, nani nani ni hantai shimasu.
Sorekara, taikou suru, kore mo ma to oppose
toka to resist no imi ga arimasu.
Sorekara, taiyou suru, kore to deal with.
Sono mondai ni taiyou shite imasu to iu no,
kore mo ni wo torimasu.
Ato tairitsu suru, kore to confront.
Nani nani to tairitsu shiteimasu.
Kono bai ni wa to wo torimasu.
Ato desu ne, zettai, kore absolute nandesu
ga.
Yoku tsukawareru no ga adverbial form de,
zettai ni,
absolutely, zettai ni sonna koto wa shimasen,
ee sonna tsukaikata wo shimasu.
Ato, taitou, kore na adjective nan desu keredomo,
equivalent to iu imi desu.
Ee, kunyomi wa arimasen.
Tsugi no kanji desu.
Ee, kono kanji desu keredomo, imi wa example
no imi ga arimasu.
De, ee, chotto ano component wo mite ikimashou.
Kono component daijoubu desu ne, kore person
toka people.
Sorekara kono migi gawa desu keredomo, kore,
retsu, line to iu imi ga arimasu.
De, chotto hen na oboekata kamoshiremasen
desu keredomo, people waiting in line to give
some samples to iu no de, sample, example
to iu imi desu.
De, ee nyomi nan desu keredomo, rei to iu
no de, re, kore wa example.
Sorekara, reibun, kore wa example sentences,
sentence.
Sorekara, reigai, kore exception desu.
Sorekara, reinen, kore wa itsumo no toshi
to iu no de, every year to iu.
Sorekara, zenrei, kore wa mae no example,
precedence desu yo ne.
Sorekara, hirei suru, kore to correlate, nani
nani to hirei shite imasu.
Konna tsukaikata wo shimasu.
Kunyomi nandesukeredo mo, yoku tsukaun no
ga tatoeba, for example to iu imi desu.
Dewa, tsugi no kanji desu.
Ee, kono kanji ano imi wa desu ne, third person
pronoun, kare toka, sorekara that
toka tte iu ano imi mo arimasu.
De component nan desu keredomo, kono hidari
gawa no radical, kore wa iku.
Kore dakara to go no aruiwa to walk sonna
imi ga arimasu.
Sorekara, migi gawa no component nandesu keredomo,
kore skin no imi ga arimasu.
So a person walking with skin ma, third person
he toka, ma sonna oboekata de iika to omoimasu.
Ee yomikata nan desu keredomo, e onyomi de,
hi to iu no ga arimasu.
Ma kore wa oboe nakutemo iikamo shirenai desu
keredomo, ano buddhism no celebration toka
yasumi de higan to iu no ga arimasu.
Kore wa haru to aki ni aru ee sono buddhism
ceremony to iu ka holiday nandesu keredomo,
sonna toki ni kore higan to iu no de, kono
kanji wo tsukaimasu.
Ee, demo minna ga ano benkyou shinakucha ikenai
no wa kono kunyomi no hou desu.
Tatoeba, kare, he.
Sorekara kanojo, she.
Karera, they desu yo ne.
Sorekara kareshi, kore wa ma, boyfriend no
imi ga arimasu.
Ee, tsugi no kanji desu.
Ee kono kanji desu keredomo, sumimasen, ee,
nandesuka, kou, oboeru story ga nain desu
keredomo, kore shita no tokoro wa tsuki, moon
no imi desu ne.
Ee imi toshite wa kore to raise no imi ga
arimasu.
Yomikata nan desu keredomo, onyomi de iku.
Tatoeba, kyouiku suru, kore wa to educate.
Ee sorekara, taiku, kore wa physical education.
Kore, karada, body no imi desu.
Sorekara, ikuji, kore wa child care.
Ee sorekara kunyomi de eeto ano soda to iu
yomikata wo suru desu keredomo, intransitive
transitive no pair ga arimasu.
Sodatsu, kore wa intransitive, nani nani ga
sodatsu.
Dakara kodomo ga sodatsu.
Sorekara, transitive no baai, sodateru, nani
nani wo sodateru.
So kodomo wo sodateru.
Kore kiotsukete kudasai.
Hai. Dewa tsugi no kanji desu.
Ee, kono kanji desu keredomo, imi wa to connect
toka person in charge no imi ga arimasu.
De, ee, component nan desu keredomo, kono
radical, radical daijoubu desu ne, kore person.
Sorekara migi gawa kono paato (part) nan desu
keredomo, kore family line to iu imi ga arimasu.
So the person belonging to the family line
is in charge to iu no de,
in charge to iu imi ga arimasu.
De, ee, yomikata nan desu keredomo, onyomi
de ee, kankei suru.
Ee, sorekara, kunyomi de ee, kaka toka kakari.
Ee tatoeba, kakawaru, to be involved.
Nani nani ni kakawaru, sono jiken ni kakawaru,
to get involved in that matter, or in that
case toka.
Sorekara kakari, to iu no de, person in charge.
Yoku iu no ga kakari no hito.
Ano sumimasen, ano sono kakari no hito wo
yonde kudasai toka.
Sonna tsukaikata wo shimasu.
Ato, annai gakari to iu no de, clerk at the
information desk.
Konna tsukaikata mo arimasu.
Ee, tsugi no kanji desu.
Ee, kono kanji desukeredo mo, imi toshite
wa to bear, to lose, to defeat, to owe
to iu imi ga arimasu.
De ma, component to iu kata oboekata nan desu
keredomo, kono ue no part, ma like its opening
mouth to iu imeeji (image) wo motte kudasai.
Sorekara kono shita no part, kore wa shell
nan desu keredomo, you use the shell as a
like a money, so if you talk open mouth, if
you talk too much about your money, you might
lose it to iu sorede lose defeat no imi ga
arimasu.
De, yomikata nan desu keredomo, onyomi de
fu to iu no ga arimasu.
Ee, tatoeba, fusai, debt.
Sorekara futan suru, kore wa to bear a burden.
Sorekara fushou suru, kore wa to get injured.
Ee sorekara, shoubu suru, to iu no de, to
have a match.
Kono toki ni wa ee, joshi particle wa nani
nani to shoubu suru.
Ee, sorekara, jifusuru, to iu no de flatter
oneself to iu imi mo arimasu.
De, kunyomi nan desu keredomo, ee, ma, o nandesuka.
Makeru, ee, to be defeated.
Tatoeba, dare dare ni, sono chiimu (team)
ni makeru, ni wo tsukaimasu.
Ato, ou nan desu keredomo, kore wa to bear
toka carry.
Ee, yoku tsukau no ga sekinin wo ou, to bear
the responsibility.
Sekinin to iu no wa responsibility to iu imi
desu.
Hai. Dewa tsugi no kanji desu.
Ee, kono kanji desu keredomo, imi wa quick,
fast, sorekara prompt to iu imi ga arimasu.
Ee chotto component wo mite ikimashou.
Ee, kono paato (part) nan desu keredomo, imi
toshite wa bundled to iu imi ga arimasu.
Ee, soshite, ee kono radical, minna yoku shitteimasu
ne, kore shinnyou nan desu keredomo, road,
walk, advance toka go toka to iu imi ga arimasu.
So if when things are bundled well, then they
can go quickly, fast to iu no de, fast toka
fast to iu imi desu.
Yomikata nan desu keredomo, onyomi de soku
to iu yomikata ga arimasu.
Tatoeba, sokudo, kore speed.
Sorekara sokutatsu, kore express delivery.
Ee, tatoeba, kono tegami wo sokutatsu de dashite
kudasai.
Mail this mail by express delivery toka.
Sorekara, sasoku, kore wa immediately.
Yoku ano business no ano nandesuka email toka
de, sasoku no ohenji doumo arigatou gozaimashita,
thanks for your prompt reply toka, sonna tsukaikata
mo arimasu.
Ato, kaisoku, kore wa high speed, express.
Kaisoku densha, express train.
Sorekara, jisoku, kore wa speed per, per hour
nandesu ga, tatoeba, shinkansen no hayasa,
mata wa, shinkansen no sokudo, spiido (speed)
wa, jisoku 320 kiro gurai desu.
Eto konna tsukaikata wo shimasu.
Sorekara, kyuusoku na, kore wa, na adjective
to rapid to iu imi desu.
Kunyomi de, hayai, kore wa quick, ii adjective
desu.
Sorekara, verb, ee, doushi nan desu keredomo,
ee, kore de hayameru, to fasten, to quicken
to iu tsukaikata, ee, transitive verb desu.
Sorekara, ee, sumiyaka na, to iu no de, speedy.
Konna adjective, na adjective nan desu keredomo,
konna tsukaikata mo arimasu.
Dewa, tsugi no kanji desu.
Ee, kono kanji desu keredomo, imi wa ability,
function.
Sorekara, Noh play no Noh to iu no imi mo
arimasu.
De, oboekata nan desu keredomo, ma amari ii
oboekata ja nai kamo shirenai desukeredo mo,
kono hidari gawa, kore eeto katakana no mu
desu.
Kore, moon, tsuki desu yo ne.
So two people sitting and looking at moons,
and talk about their abilities to iu no de,
ability, function to iu imi ga arimasu.
Yomikata nan desu keredomo, onyomi de nou,
kunyomi wa arimasen.
De, e, saki mo imashita kedo, nou, kore Noh
play no noh desu.
Sorekara, noukyoku, kore wa ability.
Sorekara, nouritsu, kore wa efficiency.
Sainou, kore wa talent.
Ee, tatoeba desu ne, ee kanojo wa sainou ga
arimasu, she has talent to iu, konna tsukaikata
wo shimasu.
Sorekara, kinou, kore wa function.
Ee, yuunou na, kore wa na adjective de capable.
Kanojo ga yuunou na hito desu, capable person.
Sorekara, kanousei to iu no de, potentiality
toka possibility.
Yoku tsukau no ga nani nani suru kanousei
ga aru, arimasu.
Tatoeba, ashita wa, ee ame furu kanousei ga
arimasu.
Konna tsukaikata wo shimasu.
Tsugi no kanji desu.
Ee, kono kanji desu keredomo, imi wa actual,
sorekara, appear, present to iu imi ga arimasu.
De, ee kono component nan desu keredomo, kono
hidari gawa, kore wa king, ou to iu imi desu.
Sorekara, kore wa daijoubu desu ne, kore wa
ee miru.
So the king is actually be seen, so he is
present and he appears, sou iu himi desu.
De, onyomi nan desu keredomo, gen to iu yomikata
ga arimasu.
Ee, tatoeba, genzai, present.
Sorekara, gendai, kore wa present day.
Genjitsu, reality, sorekara, genkin, kore
wa cash.
Ee, sorekara genjuusho, kore current ima no
address, current address.
Ee sorekara hyougen suru, kore to express.
Transitive verb desu.
Kunyomi nan desu keredomo, ee, intransitive
verb de arawareru, nani nani ga arawareru,
something appears to iu imi desu.
Tatoeba, sono hannin, hannin wa criminal,
sono hannin ga arawareta.
That criminal appeared.
Sorekara, arawasu.
Ee, kore wa transitive nan desu keredomo,
yoku tsukawareru no ga desu ne, sugata wo
arawasu, to show his figure to iu no de.
Tatoeba, kare wa sugata wo arawashita.
Konna tsukaikata mo shimasu.
Hai. tsugi no kanji desu.
Ee, kono kanji desu keredomo, imi wa to organize,
assemble, group, class, sorekara gang to iu
imi mo arimasu.
De, component nan desu keredomo, kore wa thread
desu yo ne.
Sorekara, kochira ma imagine piling up.
So people are piling up this thread to assemble
or to organize something.
Ee, to iu no de, yomikata nan desu keredomo,
onyomi de so.
Ee tatoeba, soushiki suru, to organize.
De, eeto kunyomi de wa ku toka kumi to iu
yomikata ga arimasu.
Tatoeba, kumi nan desu keredomo, ee, class,
team to iu imi ga arimasu.
Ee, yoku eeto nihon no tatoeba shougakusei,
shougakkou de desu ne, ichi nen ichi gumi
desu, tte itara, first grade home room one
to iu, konna tsukaikata wo shimasu.
Ato, kumiai, to iu no de union.
Sensei no kumiai toka.
Sorekara bangumi, kore wa program nandesukeredo
mo, yoku tsukau no ga terebi bangumi, tv program.
Konna tsukaikata wo shimasu.
Dewa, tsugi no kanji desu.
Ee, kono kanji desu keredomo, imi wa to win
toka to excel, be superior to iu imi mo arimasu.
De, ee kochira no amari ii ohanashi ja nai kamo
shirenai desu keredomo, kore moon desu yo ne,
ee sorekara kono migi gawa, this kanji
part itself means ticket to iu no ga arimasu.
Yoku tsukawareru no ga tatoeba nyuujou ken,
aru tatoeba theater
toka sorekara ekki mo sou nan desu keredomo,
hairu tame no ticket.
Sorekara joushaken, kore wa bus toka densha
ni noru eeto ken, ticket nan desu keredomo.
So someone is showing a ticket to the moon
to show off his or her win, winning to iu.
Sonna no de win toka excel to iu imi ga arimasu.
Yomikata desu keredomo, onyomi de shou to
iu yomikata ga arimasu.
Ee tatoeba, shousha, kore winner.
Kore wa hito to iu imi desu, dakara katta
hito.
Sorekara shouri, kore wa victory.
Shouhai, ee, kono kanji wa makeru to iu imi
desu.
So victory or defeat.
Sorekara kesshousen, kore wa final match.
Ee, sorekara desune game nanka de yoku, nishousanpai,
kore wa nikai katte, sankai makeru.
Mochiron sanshousanpai, ee sankai katte, sankai
makeru, iroiro na combination ga daijoubu
desu.
Sorekara, shoubu suru, kore wa to fight.
Ee dare dare to shoubu suru, to wo tsukaimasu.
Kunyomi nandesukeredo mo, eeto, kono ka, masa
to iu yomikata ga arun desukeredo mo, ma minna
ga taisetsu no hou wa ka.
Tatoeba, katsu, to win.
Ee sono team ni katsu, to win that team.
Sorekara, katte na to iu no de na adjective
nan desu keredomo, selfish to iu imi ga arimasu.
Eeto, ano hito wa honto ni katte na hito da,
he’s such a selfish person to iu tsukaikata
wo shimasu.
De, ano mo eeto kunyomi no masaru nan desu
keredomo, ee excel sorekara otomasari, to
iu no de, ma, manly to iu ee, sonna adjective
mo arimasu.
Tsugi no kanji desu.
Ee, kono kanji desukeredo mo, imi wa to break
off, sorekara come to an end to iu imi ga
arimasu.
De, ee kono kanji no component nan desu keredomo,
kore ii desu yo ne, thread.
Sorekara migi gawa kore wa color, iro desu
yo ne.
So when you see a color of thread, that comes
to the end of that thread to iu no de, ma
eeto come to the end, aruiwa break off to
iu imi desu.
Yomikata nan desu keredomo, ee onyomi de zetsu.
Ee, tatoeba, zettai, kore absolute.
Yoku tsukau no ga adverbial no tsukaikata
de zettai ni kite kudasai.
Sore, ma come by any means to iu imi desu
yo ne.
Sorekara, zekkou to iu no de, best, best condition.
Zekkou desu.
Sorekara, kono onaji ano yomikata nan desu
keredomo, zekkou suru, kore kanji ga chigaimasu.
Kono kou tte iu no wa kore wa friendship toka,
ano, nandesuka relationship no imi ga arun
desukeredo mo, so kono baai, zekkou suru tte
iu no wa to break off friendship no imi desu.
Sorekara zetsubou suru, kore wa kope, hope
ga nakunaru to iu no de, be disappointed.
Kare ni wa zetsubou shimashita.
Kono ni wo tsukaimasu.
Ato kunyomi nan desu keredomo, amari tsukaimasen
desukeredo mo, konna ano de taeru, to cease,
nani nani ga taeru.
Sorekara, nani nani wo tatsu to iu no de,
to cut toka break off to iu yomikata mo arimasu.
Hai. dewa, daiyonka no, ee, saigo no kanji.
Ee, kono kanji desu keredomo, imi wa concern
toka barrier no imi ga arimasu.
Ee component nan desu keredomo, kore wa daijoubu
desu ne, kore wa gate no imi desu.
So someone is creating some barrier inside
the gate because he or she has concern
tte iu no de, concern to iu imi desu.
De, eeto, onyomi no hou nan desu keredomo,
kan to iu yomikata desu.
Ee, kantou, kore wa tokyo no mawari no chihou.
Kansai, kore wa oosaka no mawari no chihou.
Kanto chihou, kansai chihou to iu tsukaikata
desu.
Sorekara, kansetsu, kore wa joint.
Ato, kanshin to iu no de, interest.
Nani nani ni kanshin ga arimasu.
I have interest in something.
Ato, kore, genkan, kore wa daijoubu desu yo
ne.
Ano, nihon no uchi no siono entrance, genkan
desu.
Sorekara, zeikan to iu no de, the customs
at the airport.
Ato, kankei suru, to be related.
Kankei to iu no wa relationship no imi desu.
De, kunyomi nan desu keredomo,
ano, kaka tte iu no, kakawaru, to
get involved no imi ga arimasu.
Desu kara, sono jiken ni kakawaru to iu no
wa, I get involved in that case.
Sonna tsukaikata wo shimasu.